[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, and
welcome to episode number 157
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Melanie Warrick,
and I am on my own
this week because
Mark is on vacation.
But that's all right.
He'll be back next week.
I have invited on
Anima Anandkumar
to join us this week to talk
about an upcoming conference,
a pretty well-established
conference in the AI community.
This conference will actually
be taking place next week
in particular, and
we're going to talk
about some controversy that
played out around the name
and, more specifically, the
acronym of the conference.
So that's what you're going
to hear as a core component
of our podcast this week.
The name used to be NIPS,
standing for Neural Information
Processing System, but they've
rebranded it to NeurIPS,
and we'll get into that.
As always, we start out with
cool things of the week,
and we're going to end up
with a question of the week.
And because of the
content of the podcast,
I've chosen to go
with the question of,
if you're being
trolled, or if you're
being bullied online,
what are some things you
can do about it?
So we'll get to that later.
But before that, as
I mentioned, we'll
get to our cool things of
the week, and for this week,
there's a couple of cool things
that I've unearthed for us,
or at least pulled up.
There's a blog
post that's talking
about how you can work with
the cloud DLP, the Data Loss
Prevention API in
particular, to help
with de-identifying
and obfuscating
sensitive information.
So if you work a lot
with written content,
and you need to share it--
and in this day and age,
I know there's some sensitivity
about making sure you can mask
certain things
like phone numbers,
social security numbers--
there is ways within this
API that you can integrate it
into whatever
you're working with,
or into many of
the things you're
working with, to help more
easily automate replacing,
redacting, masking--
you name it.
So information about that
API and how you can use it
will be provided
in the blog post.
Another cool thing
of the week-- there's
a nice blog post
about how you can
unlock what's possible
with medical imaging data.
So it's stepping through some
additional tools and techniques
that are being provided within
the API that was released back
in March, specifically
the Cloud Health Care API,
but outside of that as well.
In the API itself,
it's also utilizing
the de-identification
techniques that I was mentioning
from the cloud DLP,
and then there's
some codelabs that have been
provided to help you understand
how to use AI and machine
learning for health care,
as well as Kaggle is
partnering and doing
a competition with RSNA, which
for those who may not know,
the RSNA is the Radiological
Society of North America,
and they're doing a
competition specifically
on pneumonia detection.
So you can check out those types
of activities and techniques
and see how that
might be applicable.
Another cool thing is
there is a data set that
is being integrated into
and being provided as an API
through Google Cloud.
The data set is something
that Quick, Draw! has provided
and open sourced
in the last year,
but more recently is when it
was provider as an integration
to Google Cloud.
And it's 50 million
drawings, actually,
so if you want to
experiment with images
and experiment
with drawn images,
you should look into this.
And the last cool
thing of the week--
Sara Robinson, who is
one of our colleagues,
has written this
great blog post,
which is known as Machine
Learning on Machines.
So in essence, she's
built a model that
can evaluate CPU performance,
and the idea behind this model
is that she wanted to help
people understand, when you're
asking that question, of
what type of CPU setup
should I use for when I'm
doing machine learning?
Well, there's some
great content out there
that the SPEC has been building
out or has been collecting,
the Standard Performance
Evaluation Corporation.
The kind of data
they're collecting
are benchmark results on
computer performance and energy
efficiency, and so they've
looked at various setups.
They've looked at
their performance
on different types of
algorithms, on video, on audio.
So she took this information.
She then built a
model that would
help you to predict whatever
your needs are for that CPU
and whatever CPU you
have available to you,
how performant it would be.
So yeah, look at the blog post.
You'll get an understanding of
what she did, why she did it,
and how you can also either do
it yourself or use what she's
built. That's it for us for
cool things of the week,
so time to get
into the interview.
Let's go talk with Anima.
So this week I'm thrilled that
Anima Anandkumar has joined me
on the podcast.
I'm very happy to have you here.
Thank you for coming
on the podcast, Anima.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
Thank you, Melanie.
It's a pleasure.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So, Anima, I know
that you are a Bren professor
at Caltech, CMS department.
You are also the director
of machine learning research
at Nvidia, and we did a
great podcast with Bryan
earlier this year on Nvidia and
the work that he's doing there.
And you've done
significant amount
of research across the
board, especially having
significant impact in tensors--
tensor algebraic
methods, I should
say, and specifically
large scale learning,
deep learning, probabilistic
models, which is always
very hard to say quickly.
You've had a significant impact
on the space around machine
learning, around AI.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
other than what I've
already talked about,
in terms of who you are,
what your background is
in the field?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
Absolutely, Melanie.
I've had a diverse
background and worked
on a range of topics.
In fact, I started out in
electrical engineering,
working on signal processing
and information theory.
The first problem I was
looking at was sensor networks.
If we have a huge number of
sensors that are distributed,
that have to communicate
over wireless networks
and have limited battery,
how can we do learning?
And today, we've come
back to thinking about it,
if you think of
internet of things.
But about 15 years ago, that
was still a conceptual problem,
but there was a lot
of questions of what
mathematical formulations
to use and how
to think about information
in a distributed setting.
So I see this coming
a full circle,
that I started out thinking of
deeply theoretical concepts,
but today, we can realize
a lot of those dreams.
We can see those networks,
devices, out there happening,
and we can ask
what we can realize
into practical applications.
And that's why it's
such an exciting time
to be in machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
but also have this background
of multiple different areas
and a foundational theory of
information theory, machine
learning theory,
that I can build upon
to ask how to bridge that gap
between theory and practice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
So I know, whenever
people talk about tensors,
they typically will
talk about you,
and I also know that many
people will constantly
ask the question, when
they hear about tensors,
do you mean TensorFlow?
Do you want to touch
on that briefly?
Tensors are in TensorFlow,
but that doesn't necessarily
mean TensorFlow.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I
mean, the good thing
about the deep
learning revolution
is now nobody is
afraid of tensors.
Everybody has heard
of the word tensors,
whether it is TensorFlow as
a deep learning framework,
or tensor calls to do
the computations for deep
learning in Nvidia GPUs.
But there, to me,
it's not completely
realizing the potential
of tensor computations.
We still do matrix algebra
in these tensor calls,
or in our neural
network [INAUDIBLE],,
when you write a neural
network in TensorFlow,
so whereas you can expand
upon those operations
and think much more broadly.
So what does TensorFlow means?
It really means you
have a flow of tensors
throughout these
layers of processing.
The input is a tensor.
Output in general
could be also a tensor,
and you have these intermediate
operations that transform it.
And so right now, we are
doing these transformations
in somewhat simple
ways because designing
these architectures are hard.
We are going by [INAUDIBLE].
We are saying, let's
do convolutions
because there is a
translation in variance,
and this is a useful thing to
have when we do [INAUDIBLE]..
Let's then convert them
to fully connected layers
because I have to change these
three dimensional activations
of the convolutional
layer into something
I can process into
a category, which
is the output of a
classification task.
So these are going
by simple intuitions,
but we can ask what
is the next step.
Can we do much more
complex architectures,
but that can give us the benefit
of multiple dimensions, that
could potentially compress
our current networks
by large amounts, that could
help us generalize better
because it captures higher order
correlations in better and more
meaningful ways?
And that's where the tensor
algebra has the potential.
As a simple example,
if you start
with these
convolutional networks,
like I was mentioning
before, you
have these three-dimensional
activations
when you go through the
convolutional layers
because you're looking at
how the filters are acting
on the input, and you have
these so many channels
that you accumulate
when you process
through all the filters.
So you have these
three-dimensional shapes,
but when you come to
fully connected layers,
you vectorize it.
You ignore all this
three dimensionality.
You just treat it
as a vector, and you
do matrix multiplication with
the fully connected layer,
and you pass on the results
through few such layers
and, finally, get the output,
which is the classification.
And so instead, we
asked, what if you'd
kept the three
dimensional information
all the way through?
Even in the fully
connected layer,
you maintain the
three dimensionality.
You contract the
tensor, which means
you're looking at three separate
weight matrices for the three
dimensions, and
you're learning them,
and when you're doing
regression in the last layer,
you're doing a low rank
parameterized weights.
That means you can have a much
more compact set of parameters
that can give you
the same accuracy.
In fact, we found more
than 65% space savings
in these fully connected
layers by incorporating
the multi-dimensionality.
And what I have ambitions for
is to take it to the next level
and ask, suppose I can
realize entirely new
architectures by looking
at these higher order
tensor operations.
What would they be, and what
kind of an impact can it make?
Especially if you think of
multi-modal information--
it's not just images.
It's image and text
and other information.
We have this explosion
of dimensionalities.
Can we naturally encode
them with tensors
and carry it all the way
throughout the network.
MELANIE WARRICK: And that's
the next level of your research
that you're currently
involved in,
in terms of what you're
going forward with.
So one of the other
questions I wanted
to ask you before
we dive into some
of the meat of the
additional things
we were going to talk about
during this podcast is,
can you tell us a
little bit about what
you do as the
director of machine
learning research at Nvidia?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Yeah, so I'm
very excited to be at Nvidia.
It's been two months now.
That's gone very fast because--
MELANIE WARRICK: So you must
have solved all the problems
there.
[LAUGHING]
[INAUDIBLE] no problem.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I only wish.
I only wish.
I'm so happy to have
amazing colleagues.
Bill Dally is the
chief scientist here.
Bryan Catanzaro, Jan Kautz,
and researchers from also
the computer graphics side,
architecture, hardware.
It's this interdisciplinary
nature of research here
and also the engineering
prowess and the scalability
that Nvidia offers.
I'm very excited to think
of research problems
at the core of machine
learning, like the example of,
can we realize new neural
network architectures
but really realize
them at scale?
It's the full stack solution.
Can we think of better hardware,
better [INAUDIBLE] primitives,
better frameworks that make
it easy to design and realize
the algorithms?
And that's what makes
Nvidia so exciting to me,
because I can translate
that into practice.
I can see the real
gains, but I'm also
given the freedom and a
team and the expertise
to ask how we can
realize those new dreams.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
have this expertise
from the mathematical
and theoretical side
that you're also now able to
translate into this hardware
applied side of the world.
It sounds pretty fantastic
to be able to marry the two.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Absolutely,
and Nvidia, to me,
is the best place to do that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's wonderful.
Let me go ahead and shift gears
and talk a little bit about--
from the AI and the
machine learning space.
I know you've been in the
academic field clearly
for years now, and the space
is well-known for having
some conferences that
are pretty established
for bringing together academics
to be able to share research,
to share knowledge.
There's ones that stand out
as sort of the core ones,
although there's
a ton of them that
allow people to come together
for various specialties.
Can you tell us a little
bit about those conferences,
why they matter so
much in this field?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Indeed.
Back a few years ago--
well, going back when the
deep learning revolution
hadn't happened, then it
was these small academic
conferences.
For instance, having 700 or
800 was such a big number,
and most of them
were small workshops.
And that was the only way
to disseminate information.
You'd go actually
talk to the person
and get the full
understanding of the paper
during the poster
session, so you
have these very deep
conversations there.
And so to me, since I didn't
start out my PhD in this field,
I kind of moved towards the end
of my PhD to machine learning,
although the tools
I was using was
very relevent to solving
machine learning problems,
I found the community
so welcoming.
I submitted the papers to NIPS--
now, what's called in NeurIPS--
and ICML and other conferences,
and I felt instantly
welcomed because there
was deep reviews.
There was pages of very
deep technical discussions
during the review process,
and the community was small.
It was well-knit, and we
made a lot of progress
in the conferences in terms
of intellectual engagements.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
those have evolved
as neural nets, as machine
learning, have taken hold.
I've seen these conferences,
and as you mentioned, NIPS--
which is now NeurIPS--
has gone from, I guess it
was only a few hundred to--
what was it-- 8,000
not that long ago.
I'm not sure what
it is this year.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: It would--
I mean, it could be much more
if there was no limit on--
MELANIE WARRICK: Probably.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: [INAUDIBLE].
MELANIE WARRICK: So
part of the reason
why I set this podcast up
was because I wanted us
specifically to dive into NIPS,
which the Neural Information
Processing Systems conference.
Some out there, especially
those in the academic field,
may have heard about
the controversy that
played out this
year in particular
in terms of renaming it.
I think it sounds, just by us
saying the acronym, for many
who have never heard of this
conference it might make sense.
But unfortunately, it did
receive a lot of resistance.
Can you talk to
that a little bit,
about what transpired the naming
change, why this was an issue?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: So
being in the community
before the deep learning
revolution, like I said,
it was a small,
well-knit community then.
And the name, you know, you
think for it for a minute.
But then you go
to the conference,
you have these
friendly discussions,
and you have such an
amazing experience,
then that's not
the primary focus.
I'm very proud of the
tradition that the conference
has spawned.
In fact, the conference
started out here at Caltech,
was founded here at Caltech.
Not many people know that.
MELANIE WARRICK: No.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
And I'm extremely
proud of that tradition.
And it was started by Professor
Yaser Mostafa and Ed Posner
here.
And in fact, it was
forward thinking
in the view of
marrying neuroscience
and machine learning together.
And that's why there is neuro
and there is processing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: And that was
the goal of that conference.
But once the community
started exploding
with deep learning taking
off, which is great,
but a side effect was
these conferences grew out
of proportion.
There's a lot of issues of how
we are even enabling entrance
into these events.
And it's this
first-come-first-serve,
which I have a lot
of issues with.
So there's one issue of how to
manage the population entering
the conferences.
The other is the
behavior, right?
So when you have lots of
newcomers into the community,
there's so many people
looking for attention.
And for them, it's this
kind of quick attention
because they have
to hire talent.
And so you have this
hedge fund that no one
had heard of printing
t-shirts that say,
like, "My NIPS are
[INAUDIBLE] hard."
I think that's the
very first time I saw
the name being used that way.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
And just this hedge
fund giving out these t-shirts
during the event, right?
And they got their notoriety.
They got people
to pay attention.
So I see why they had
the incentive to do that.
And that started increasing.
So to me, it's this
infusion of bro culture.
When people feel like it's a
gold rush, it's been shown time
and again there
is a lot of people
who want to enter
to make a quick buck
or to somehow quickly
gain a profit.
And that, to me, really has
destroyed the academic fabric
and the intellectual
pursuit of the conference.
And in a way, we are all still
grappling with that change,
right?
How do we deal with it?
How do we manage this?
How do we keep it professional?
We indeed want the
community to grow.
We indeed want
democratization of AI.
We wanted to reach out to
much bigger populations,
and we want them to
think about AI problems.
But how do we do it in a
way while still maintaining
the intellectual
exchange and while still
maintaining professionalism?
So to me, these
issues are on the name
and the way the name was
used to harass women,
to talk about
women's body parts,
is a reflection of the
cultural change that's
been coming into AI community.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Why do you think
that these conferences
have gotten so big
and are so important for people
to attend now versus before?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Now it's
become a gold rush, right?
It's really a rush.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So the gold rush?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: In terms
of hiring the talent,
hiring the researchers.
So the companies
have done a lot.
So a lot of amazing things of
taking AI to the real world.
But there is also
the challenge of how
do we still maintain
the intellectual pursuit
and have avenues for
intellectual exchange,
and separate that from
the aspects of hiring
and recruiting, right?
And I think that many
other fields that
do these large
conferences very well,
there can be very
well-established protocols.
But we have seen
this growth so fast,
and I feel that the boards
of these machine learning
conferences haven't
managed to adapt,
because I think there needs to
be some new infusion of ideas
there.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That makes sense.
So where we're at now, this year
in particular, the conference
took a step back and did
an assessment of the name.
Do you know what helped
them take an assessment
and consider changing the name?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: So like
I was saying last year
was, to me, like where it
kind of all topped off.
Like a few years ago, the deep
learning revolution started,
and we saw all these new
people and huge crowds coming
to the conferences
and the character
of the conferences changing.
And then there were so many
corporate parties and events
and other outside
events, that became
almost the central
attraction compared
to the main conference.
And so when those
started multiplying,
there was no code of conduct.
There were no
standards established.
And so people, to
get attention, again,
were doing things that
were outside the norms
of professional conduct.
The primary goal that
most researchers have,
and especially a lot of
women researchers have,
is to go talk about
intellectual things,
to talk about actual
machine learning research
and not worry about being
made fun of their body parts.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
And I'd heard outside
of these parties
and some additional content
that was released and published
around various harassment
that folks have experienced
at this conference
and other conferences,
I'd also read that there
was an open letter in March
from Johns Hopkins University,
that the faculty there
were asking the
board specifically
to change the name.
That was something
that I had come across
as another component that
played into all of this.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Absolutely.
Professor Elana Fertig
was in touch with me,
and she was telling me of all
the efforts from Johns Hopkins.
And that's when I even started
plugging into this issue more.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I
was bothered by it,
but I realized it bothered
the younger women even much
more than what I
could feel, right?
And to me, this is
coming from an angle
of not something affecting
me personally as much.
I mean, I was angry about it.
But for others, it was
much more than that, right?
They literally felt like they
were not welcome in the event
or even welcome to
be an AI researcher.
And that, to me,
is catastrophic.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
So the board did do
a survey this year,
and they came out
with their results.
And that was like a couple of
months back where they said,
you know, we're not
going to make the change.
And they gave this
statistical analysis
on why they're not going
to make the change.
So you took a reaction to that.
Can you talk to that a little
bit-- about the results
and what steps you took
after you saw the results?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I mean,
I was, first of all,
disturbed that there was
a survey asking everybody
that there should
be a name change.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: That,
to me, was already
a problematic starting
point, because on Twitter,
when I publicly supported
the name change,
and other women were
doing, there were already
behaviors of trolling.
There were men writing
to me saying, oh,
both men and women have nipples.
What's the big deal?
They don't even understand.
That's already a problem there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: So
the survey was already
an avenue for people to
debate it in an unhealthy way,
because this is an issue that
is not affecting the majority.
The majority of men,
especially senior men,
have never had to
worry about it.
That's the privilege they have.
And they may find it funny.
They may laugh at
it for a minute.
But that's the end of it.
That's the only
effect it has on them.
But on especially
the junior women,
the more and more
I heard on how they
felt so unwelcome and negative.
And that's combined with
everything else, the parties,
the bro culture, the
aggressiveness in how
some people push their
research versus other voices
are getting drowned.
So to me, the
reflection of all this
was being played out with
the name change debate.
The majority was
being asked to make
a decision on an issue that
didn't affect them adversely.
And on the other hand,
a name change to me
is something so simple to do.
As we saw in the end,
it's not that hard.
It's literally, go and
change on the website
and on social media.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
It costs nothing.
And people are arguing,
oh, it's symbolic.
But why don't we start with
at least something symbolic?
Let's start there.
This shouldn't be the end point.
But if you start there,
you send a message.
You send a message to
all the young women
that their voices are heard,
their concerns are heard.
And we will do
anything to make them
more comfortable and welcome.
And it will also send a
message to all these bros
that are making fun of the
name and really destroying
the professional nature
of the conference
that this will not
be taken lightly.
And hopefully over time, we can
have a strong code of conduct
that will actually make
this behavior accountable.
And so that's the path
I'm hoping this will take.
But this is where the name
change, the way the decisions
were made, the way the
survey was designed,
and it was also a
biased sample that
was asked to take the survey.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: So it
was all the attendees,
I believe, over the
last five years.
But how about so many
women who could not attend,
which again goes back
to my issue of access
to these conferences.
If it's like a
first-come-first-serve,
if you're comparing
this to the Burning Man,
if you are comparing this to
these hot tickets getting sold
out, think about young
women who may, first of all,
be not so confident if they
even want to go to conference,
or if they have challenges in
getting the travel support.
Both men and women in
the junior positions
who are even thinking about
it but haven't managed,
they will be the ones who
will lose out the most.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: And
those in academia,
because they may not
have the same resources
that they have in industry.
So this has been an
extremely biased sample
of both men and women who
were asked to take the survey.
And my view is, it was
not affecting them.
It was affecting
more people who are
about to enter the community.
The more junior people,
they are much more
adversely affected than the
senior people who are well
established in the community.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
also think I've yet
to meet someone who's never
heard of the conference
before, that, when you
tell them the name,
they don't immediately
think that it's
an inappropriate
acronym to be using.
But when the results
were given, you
responded by
starting a petition.
You specifically started out
with the protestNIPS hashtag,
and then also created a
petition on change.org.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I should admit
I was really late to the party.
There was a lot
of hard work done
at the grassroots level, a
lot of women speaking out
on Twitter.
And as I said, from Johns
Hopkins University, Dr. Elana
Fertig and so many others, they
coordinated with the Title IX
office there,
drafted this letter,
got all these
researchers to sign this.
So they've done so much
groundwork to begin with.
And when I came
in, I was thinking,
let's take this broader, right?
Let's kind of open up
to not just machine
learning people,
everybody on Twitter.
Because the general
population will
be so shocked to see this
acronym is a real thing, right?
And that's where I tried
to de-bias the samples,
because not just the
people who have already
been in the community
and take this name
for granted, but fresh voices
that have a real issue with it.
And I really wanted to
see the board take notice.
So I essentially repurposed
the letter from Johns Hopkins
and put that on
change.org to reach out
to the broader community.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
So then what happened
after this petition?
You've already talked to
how people have rebelled
against the name change,
but what kind of reaction
did you get when you started
publicly speaking out
against this?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I got a lot
of support that I'm so happy,
and I find that
very fulfilling how
the community came
behind me, and so
many men and women retweeting.
Jeff Dean immediately
retweeted, and he
wanted to think of getting the
companies to be accountable
and supporting this
name change, right?
So that to me really
amplified the voice.
So there were so many
amazing researchers
who really helped amplify this.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: And that
was the majority, right?
So like the majority are
amazing, good-hearted people.
And then there was
a small section
who were genuinely questioning.
And they were really confused.
Many of them were
not native speakers.
They kind of didn't
know the short form,
or they didn't kind of
really get this immediately.
So that's why I had
put the Google image
search to even begin with that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's great impact.
Visuals are wonderful
for these things, yes.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: So
that smaller section
of people who were
openly speaking out.
They spoke with
their real identities
but had genuine questions.
Most of them came around.
I would say most of
them at least realized,
yes, it may not have
affected them, and that's OK.
But it's affected
so many others.
So they saw all
these voices that
were saying that they
were adversely affected.
And then they realized
they need to support this.
And so that, to me, was
the best part of it,
because how many people who
are in this neutral or moderate
position, who just are not even
aware of the issues affecting
the minorities?
But when we bring
this out into the open
and have a dialogue,
that we can really
get this information exchange,
and we can increase empathy.
And that was the most
fulfilling part of it.
But there was also
the negative side.
There was a lot of trolling.
No surprise.
All of it was anonymous.
And then there was
the Reddit thread
that personally
was abusive to me
in so many appallingly
distasteful ways.
I got a lot of the accounts
that I now had to block.
I really had to keep pushing
Reddit to remove those.
And it took extensive
ones, and still there
is some that are still there.
So this brings out the concern
that anybody having a voice
pushing for inclusivity
or diversity
is heavily trolled
on social media.
And we have so
little control on how
to avoid this hateful speech.
And that to me is
really disturbing
because it prevents so many
women from speaking up.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's true.
I'm hesitant to ask, but
partially want to ask.
How bad was the
trolling for you?
Are you willing to talk a
little bit about how bad it got?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Sure.
And in my Twitter thread, I did
post some of those screenshots
because I wanted people to
be aware of how bad it is.
So many men were shocked because
they've never seen anything
like that happen to them.
They've never been
personally subjected
to such kind of
harassment and trolling.
It was commenting on my looks.
It was commenting on
my professionalism.
It was saying that I just
got up to this position
because I'm a
woman, and how can I
be so not thankful to all
the men who have helped me.
It was all this.
They called me a
radical feminist.
And I know another
woman who went on Reddit
and tried to answer
to these trolls.
She was bullied.
She was physically
threatened with a gun.
And this is a professor
who is a public figure.
And then you really start
to wonder how dangerous this
could all get.
And then the worst
thing was not just
the personal trolling
that I was receiving,
but how other young women
were bullied through all this.
And I was receiving emails from
so many young women saying--
and also young men--
saying that when they were
discussing it with others,
that I was just being trolled.
I was kind of looked down upon.
And sometimes the advisors
would tell their students
not to sign the
petitions publicly
or never to lend their
voice to this even
though they wanted to.
So you could say, oh, this
is a harmless name change.
But it opened up this underbelly
of harassment and bullying.
MELANIE WARRICK: Viciousness.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Yes.
There's so much-- that's
the word, viciousness.
If it was so simple
and easy to do,
then why are people behaving
so viciously about it?
MELANIE WARRICK: It's atrocious.
And there's not really
enough right words,
but something that's in my head
right now that I need to say
is thank you.
Thank you for fighting
for the change.
In addition to the others
who have done that,
thank you for putting
the energy to that,
because this isn't your job.
This shouldn't be your job.
It shouldn't be anyone's job.
And thank you for continuing
to be a leader in the field
and not leaving
because of the things
that you've seen
and experienced.
So thank you.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
Thank you, Melanie.
Thank you for
amplifying the voice,
and thank you for
all the support
when, as all this was unfolding,
you were messaging me.
You were being such a
great source of support.
And that's where I found
all these amazing allies.
We grew stronger that
way, and we know next time
to do more meaningful
changes, who the people are.
Now I know my community.
Now I know the allies.
And that's so important.
And yes, I'm here to stay,
trolling or otherwise.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
That's not going to--
that's only going
to make me stronger.
And that'll only-- you know, the
days of trolling are numbered.
I would really like
to see big changes,
and I would like
to do everything
that I can to not
only limit trolling,
but to limit all these kinds of
bad behavior in the community
and in the wider space.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
Transitioning back,
you had the petition,
and between doing the petition
and all the things that you've
been through and the support
that you've received,
it seems like the
board has reconsidered,
because just recently
before the conference,
they released a change.
And the change is
somewhat of a compromise.
Instead of changing
the full name,
they're now changing--
you know, they're
keeping Neural Information
Processing Systems,
but the acronym is
going to be NeurIPS.
So kind of like stirrups,
but not exactly.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
That's not the picture
I would like in my mind, but--
MELANIE WARRICK: What's that?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I said,
I don't want the picture
of stirrups in my mind.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
It's that word that
keeps coming into my head
every time I hear people
say the new acronym.
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Maybe the
[? turnips ?] is a more--
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
So what do you think
of the new name?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I think the
new name is a nice compromise.
I would have liked to
start with a clean slate,
because that wouldn't
have been any harder.
But I mean, I'm happy that
we came up to this point.
And as I said, it's much
more about the name.
It's all the forces
that came into the open
when we were debating
this name change.
That's the one we need
to work a lot more on.
So I'd really like to
move to the next steps.
I would really like to see
a much more impactful code
of conduct.
The current one
has been amazing.
It was done in a
short amount of time.
Hal Daumé and Katherine Heller
just did an amazing job to put
that together.
But now I want to ask,
what are the repercussions
if somebody does not meet that?
There has to be
real repercussions,
and only then it
should have teeth.
So these are the things
we need to ask ourselves
as the next steps.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Is there anything
that you'd recommend
for those who
might want to help promote
inclusivity in the field?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Have a
professional interaction
and be very mindful if
you're talking to people
who are more junior to you.
Even the actions you
don't even think about
may have a big impact on them.
And communicate better.
See if people are
feeling comfortable
when you're talking to them.
So I would start
with those basics.
I think Jeff Dean had an
amazing Twitter thread where
he crowdsourced experiences
of women researchers
and conferences and negative
experiences they had.
And then he said, oh, these are
the things you shouldn't do.
For instance, in the very
first conference I went to,
my advisor is great.
He introduced me to another
senior male researcher,
a professor.
And he left, you know,
so he introduced me.
He had to go talk
to somebody else.
He left, and he
said, go further,
take over this conversation.
And then that professor told
me, oh, let me introduce you
to my female graduate student.
Because you both are women, you
will get along better with her.
I mean, like that, to me,
was just like-- you know,
I'm a starting researcher.
I really would like to
talk to this senior person
that I looked up to.
And this is just--
for him it seems so natural, but
it had such a bad impact on me.
And it's important for women
to express all these kinds
of behaviors that made them
feel uncomfortable, unwelcome,
diminished, and then for men
to think about taking notice,
and then to open
this up even broader
to other diversity groups.
I know Black in AI has seen
amazing effort into diversity.
I mean, we had
researchers coming
from countries that
never had anybody attend
these conferences before.
That to me shows there's so
much work to be done there.
But they've also
received heavy trolling,
undergoing a lot of issues.
So to me, yes, we
start with women now,
because I can mirror
those experiences.
I understand them.
But I want to understand how is
it impacting the other groups?
What are the issues
the others are
facing that I may never have?
I have my own
privileges, but others
come from different backgrounds
and are facing more issues.
How can we address
everybody's issues?
MELANIE WARRICK: I think
that's a great point.
And we are releasing
this podcast the week
before the conference,
the NeurIPS conference.
And the workshops,
as you mentioned,
like Black in AI
and LatinX and WIML.
So now that the name
has been changed,
there has been the
compromise, what
are you looking forward to
in terms of the conference?
What are some of the areas in
which you're excited about,
that you think are
great to keep an eye on,
outside of that diversity
efforts that are going on
to help bring in more
researchers into this space?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: Absolutely.
To me, going to
these conferences
has always been about
the new innovations.
Like what are the new technical
breakthroughs, and also
so much of what young people are
doing, like young researchers,
like how we can further
nurture and encourage them?
If they are coming for the
conference for the first time
or presenting the
paper, how can I
take that to the next level,
how I can communicate with them
on all the broader pictures?
So that's where I get the
most out of these conferences.
And in the workshops,
a lot more exchange
can happen because
it's much more organic.
It's much more work that
has just started or is
in preliminary stages, right?
So there is a lot more
room for brainstorming,
for giving feedback,
for receiving feedback.
In the past I've had just
so many results that derive
during the conference.
I'd just sit,
brainstorm with people,
and come up with new ideas.
And now, as the community has
scaled, that has become harder.
But I would like to still
pursue some of this.
And this is where we need
to control the crowds,
and we need to find ways that
make this more manageable.
In fact, I tend to do
this more at WIML or Black
in AI because they're
smaller events,
and I can talk at a personal
level and exchange ideas.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Two last questions,
one being, you've
done a lot of interviews.
Any questions that nobody asks
you that you wish somebody
would ask?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR:
So people have asked
me a lot about industry
versus academia
because I'm in both sides.
And I see the good and
bad in each of them.
And so most of the
questions typically
are about how industry
is snatching away
the academic talent.
How can we avoid
it or change that?
And for that I always
say, look, there
are lots of positive impacts,
because many professors
like me are dividing time
between both industry
and academia and really
helping in this transfer
of information, not only from
academia to industry, but back.
So the question that nobody
has ever asked me before
is how is industry impacting
academia in a positive way,
and what are still
unrealized [INAUDIBLE]??
Because there are also
lots of frustrations
to me and to other researchers
with the current academic
system.
And that, to me,
is the way research
is so much focused
on publications,
but also so little focused on
creating software frameworks,
creating a community effort
where people can really
build an ecosystem and think
about modular softwares that
will benefit others, not
only that they have done
some research,
done their own code
and they are writing this
paper and publishing this.
And that's, to me, industry
has changed this game,
because the impact is coming
from having these open source
frameworks, and the
community is using it
and contributing to this.
And so what I really hope
for, and what I'm pushing for,
is how can we do this in
other disciplines of sciences?
The problem is, in the
other basic sciences,
there is no industry
doing this now.
No industry is doing
any research on this.
So what about all
of these other areas
that are not
disrupted by industry?
I would like to see
disruption, disruption
in the sense of how
the incentives are
aligned in better ways.
How we can really
remove these barriers
that are mostly
sociological, because there
was this very old
legacy code that
was used in some high-energy
physics, where nobody even
understands what's going on.
It's still being used today.
Even when we have
billions of dollars
of experiments being done,
the experimental part
takes so much resources.
And that's where the
grants go to funding them.
But on the computational
side, ultimately
to enable AI into
those applications,
there are basic barriers.
They may seem sociological
and more mundane--
they're not a
mathematical barrier--
but they are important barriers.
And I don't have a good
answer on how to disrupt that.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a good question, though.
Anything else that you wanted
to touch on before I let you go?
ANIMA ANANDKUMAR: I wanted
to thank you again, Melanie.
It's been wonderful that you
have asked so many questions
where I could really express
the emotions I was going through
as I went through
this protestNIPS
and be engaged
with the community.
I really appreciate you
amplifying this voice
and lending support.
I'm really thankful
for this, and thank you
for doing this podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, thank
you for coming and sharing
the story with us.
I really appreciate it, Anima.
OK, question of the week.
If you are dealing with any
type of bullying or trolling
or you're concerned
about this, what
are some things you can do?
Well, I've included in
here a couple of links
that you can check out.
There is some great information
from the Electronic Frontiers
Foundation for surveillance,
self-defense, tips and tools.
I would not recommend reading
it all in one sitting.
I would say go in
there, look around, pick
and choose what makes sense.
And also Feminist
Frequency has provided
some wonderful information
to help step you
through ways to better
protect yourself online.
This isn't a foolproof process.
This isn't a perfect process.
But at least it's
something you can
do if you are interested
in taking certain steps.
And they're not the
only ones out there
who have provided content,
so you can definitely
do some searching
to explore further.
All right, so where
are we all going to be?
Well, as we've been
talking about it,
Mark will be at
KubeCon in December.
So if you're going to be
there, KubeCon, Koob-Con,
however you pronounce it, you
should go and say hello to him.
And then I will be at
SOCML actually this week.
And next week, as I
mentioned, will be NeurIPS.
If you're going to be
in the area of Montreal,
you should definitely check
out some of the workshops.
WIML is going to be on
December 3, and Black in AI
is going to be on
December 7, and LatinX
will be on December 8.
So if you're there, go by.
Check out these
different communities.
They're good ones to be
learning from, especially
in the AI space.
That's it for us for
this week on the podcast.
So thank you for joining us,
and we'll talk to you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]